Is your name Hakkon?
Welcome. Could Hakkon be a human soul inhabiting a magic tool? Come on. Well, I'm going to
ask you some questions now. If I'm
wrong, feel free to ask me. Welcome.
These days...  It's a pity that it's a magic tool that has a master.So, do you
have any memories of when you were a human?I see.I see.There
shouldn't be any need for money for magic tools in the first place, so why is the price set?  Do you
need it to replenish it?
I'm sorry. I'm not
completely wrong. Are
there other things you can do with money? Welcome, now. I think it would be
faster to actually show it to you. The
shape has completely changed.  It seems like the
products they sell are different too.It would
be weird if it wasn't a vending machine.I see, you can use the money you earn to change the functions of the 8 machines.What
else
?
[Music] What's this? [
Music] It's
like a wall, and it seems pretty strong. Let's
surprise you a little.
[Music] It's a
strong wall that can be maintained as you like. This is
n't a barrier, is it? It's an amazing box.  It has so many functions and can even
use
divine protection, which is beyond the scope of a magic tool.I'm
happy to be praised, but I've just been
given the body of an excellent vending machine.What I'm really
proud of is her intelligence.Her own intelligence.
Because I'm using my power to derive the answer.